hey what's this young will sasso want
from us
you see will has a new show yeah dude
straight up
show fellow thick boy jacob oh wow from
the great state of utah
uh my birthday is coming up in a couple
of days happy birthday me and my wife
reflect on
some folks in our life that are
grown-ass adults
that are strangely obsessed with their
own birthdays roof
they want everyone to know it's multiple
um
social media posts nothing works every
single day leading up to the birthday
so can you sing it grown ass adults
that are weirdly obsessed with their own
birthdays
not in my butt
[Laughter]
he says shout out to the black henry hey
i appreciate that
dude shout out to the thick boy nation
over there man think boy bike club dog
yeah what's up jacob man i think uh yeah
some people
strangely obsessed with their birthdays
i find that to be
i wonder if there's certain types of
people that are though or not yeah it is
weird it's annoying to me i feel like
after
21 no one gives a [ __ ] about your
birthday dude i forgot my brother's
birthday last week
i've been so stressed out with this i
forgot his birthday
i was like why because we you know we
text nonstop throughout the day with
business stuff
i'm like damn why isn't this full of
getting back to me like what's wrong
with you and then
i go what are you doing he goes dad just
stopped by to drop off my birthday
present like wow
so i had to
came late but i got something what'd you
get him
i got him some uh these dunks well now
he knows
i got him these uh oakland a dunks that
just dropped
oh those are nice man nice little nice
little hair brotherly love
man there you guys are right there
that's us at yuck yucks in calgary
eating chinese food next door it's our
favorite chinese food hey man bro
what are you guys up there a year or two
ago huh uh yeah probably
you saw brett the hitman hard huh yep oh
this one you saw i brought the hit man
hard huh he came in all
sweats and [ __ ] oh yeah and then stared
through my brother's soul
otherwise i brought the hitman hard huh
[Laughter]
hey take my daddy off the screen dude
that's what you should grill up will's
calves dude that's
one of your first meats that you have
will's brisket calves yeah
always got big calves oh yeah dude the
biggest you've ever seen in your life
you've never seen bigger legs than will
sasso's cats really oh dude they're
africa they call them cats they're huge
dude if you put your ears titanic there
he is put your team you can hear people
starving in them dude
that's his cat that's his calf yeah
people are yelling out like it's the
size of brian's head and also brian had
hair there
and brian's putting his ear up to it
yeah ironically
his calves are huge oh my god i didn't
know he had that
did brian have coveted right there no i
don't think well
i'm a little salty because we invited
him back on the podcast and he didn't
come on
he well he won't leave his house during
copenhagen he won't it was around
christmas though
oh he was busy though he's got a show
called i got nothing that's true i
didn't know they had a show coming up oh
sorry he has this show he's doing
abc can do your podcast trust me
yeah it's crazy i know breaks my heart
dude
so viewers on the pod that's what would
have got him what um
what is the what is the show let's do a
shout out for today uh i don't know what
to bring it up nick
but it's him it's like it looks really
good it looks kind of like kings of
queen remember that
oh yeah it was like kings of queen but
and listen will when you talk about
talent
out of our group of friends will's right
there yeah
will's talented as a [ __ ] dude
united we fall so we gotta go watch that
yeah go watch it yeah i'm gonna i'm
gonna put it on there well will's one of
the funniest people in the world
too funny man dude he's so funny man
he worked so hard to get this
opportunity i'd like a role on the show
please well it's already been shot but
yeah oh never mind maybe season two
should be
okay okay so would that guy ask
we got him you want to move on
[Music]
is